E aí
[Música]
[Aplausos]
E aí
bom e tudo começa no silêncio
15 Hoje em dia a sociedade a
extremamente barulhenta estás
treinamentos cheio de distrações E
andamos muito rápido sem sequer ter
tempo para respirar e muito interessante
também não vir este hora dores que eles
tiveram as porque é muito interessante
escutar outras perspectivas da mesma
face humana que vivemos todos uma menos
científica outro mais científica a eu
considero um primeiro explorador de som
e para conseguir explorar este som eu
tenho que aceitar primeiro
o silêncio faz parte de tudo desse
infinito e quando me convidaram para
falar desse infinito e ver todo o prazer
em vir partilhar essa perspectiva do
silêncio que está em nós e que que é
muito interessante escutá-lo e eu
pergunto pergunto-me a mim quase todos
os dias como estou em mim
Oi como é que está a minha respiração
Oi como é que está a minha vida porque
essa respiração está
é completamente conectada com o modo de
vida e a partir do momento em que
tiramos um tempo para escutar por ouvir
toda a gente faz o cérebro está
constantemente a ouvir-me às vezes temos
de uma praça cheia de dimensão a gente a
falar à venda em fruta e coisas mas a
partir do momento em que alguém chama o
teu nome o teu servo viajo e a partir
daquele momento mais nada existe a não
ser aquela pessoa e ficamos
inconscientemente é incrível não é de
repente a esse beco nós desaparece e
ficamos plenamente atendidos a
E eu pergunto-me então como é que nós
conseguimos alcançar essa esse essa
Plenitude essa consciência de estar
consciência de ser a e eu encontro muito
através do Sol através deste instrumento
que chama a gente já o topo há dez anos
foi uma ferramenta que me ajudou
bastante a conhecer a mim próprio a
trazer consciência de quem sou a
Eu trouxe um também essa consciência de
saber escutar não só com os meus ouvidos
mas cinco com as minhas células do corpo
inteiro que elas carregam os nomes que
elas carregam essa informação genética
que toda a gente sabe E E que esse livro
pedir a pesar 250 quilogramas e podemos
passar já não lembro do estádio da horta
da trabalhadora mas foi extremamente
interessante escutar e perceber essa
perspectiva A então a mensagem que eu
quero trazer aqui a
nós sabemos parar um pouco
a escutar Como está nossa respiração
Ah e não só ouvir mas parar escutar ir
nós podemos trazer muito de cura as
outras pessoas porque toda a gente nesta
sociedade quer falar queres Porque o
Queres que quer ser reconhecida quero
quero quero atenção as crianças mostram
isso os pais estão constantemente
ocupados e nós adultos também queremos
um bocado disso e procuramos já pagamos
a pessoas que fazem psicanálise
terapeutas e psicólogos Porque queremos
realmente alguém nos olhos e
e eu acho que é muito importante nós
resgatamos novamente esse dom de saber
ouvir esse dom de saber escutar não só
que os ouvidos Mas com todo nosso ser eu
acho que essa é a mensagem que quero
deixar aqui nesta Deca obrigado eu sou a
canção